it feels like we should start with the
obligatory question that all partitions
are being asked at the moment as Shadow
Health Secretary though it is quite
relevant have you done drugs and do you
care that Michael Gove has no I've never
taken any illegal drugs actually and in
some ways I don't really care about what
Michael Gove got up to any in his 30s
when he was a journalist but I do think
the conversation in this country
shouldn't be about what the various Tory
candidate Tory leadership candidates
have done I think the conversation in
this country should be about whether how
we deal with drugs in society the
so-called war on drugs the way in which
we incarcerate people with who have
taken drugs and actually visiting a
prison tomorrow friendly enough to look
at their drug support teams isn't
working when we've got some of the
highest when three and half thousand
people die from drug misuse in this
country every year that's double the
numbers who died from car accidents for
example whether drug overdose capital in
Europe I think it's time we had a debate
about drugs in this country should be
you should take a public health approach
well I think we should take a public
health approach to drugs so for example
drug consumption rooms are not allowed
in this country the home office has
turned down applications from Glasgow
City Council recently to set up a drug
consumption room I don't think the
current approach is working as I say we
should have a public health approach to
drugs in this country we've also cooked
by the way other could not we the
government have cut around 160 million
from drug and alcohol addiction services
and this is at a time when more and more
people are dying from drugs there's more
admissions to hospitals related to drugs
for mental health problems related to
drugs or poisoning related to substance
misuse so we're getting it wrong in this
country and I think that's where the
conversation should be a mature debate
about drugs and how we deal with drugs
for the future and how about
decriminalization well I certainly think
decriminalization should be part of that
debate and I strongly would urge the
government to think again about good
consumption rooms this is where people
can okay come off the streets can use
needles safely at the moment we are
criminalizing people unnecessarily and
it's leading to deaths in society and
it's because politicians have run scared
of this debate for too long so I think
that's where the conversation needs to
be not whether what that what this Tory
candidate or that toy candidate has done
in some ways I don't really think that
it's not so it's not really relevant
there was a bigger debate we need to
have in society okay now labour has done
some research haven't you into NHS
waiting times for patients what exactly
is it that you found well we're finding
that people are waiting longer 250,000
won nearly 260 thousand people waiting
beyond 18 weeks for treatment and huge
increases in the numbers of people
waiting for treatment and often these
are these are these are people waiting
for treatment for very serious problems
whether it's to do with Parkinson's or
whether it's to do with various
dermatological problems I mean it's it
is because we've had years now of the
NHS being underfunded quite desperately
I understand the government have changed
the budgets for the NHS but it's not
enough but also it's because we have a
hundred thousand fakin C's across the
NHS we're short of 40 thousand nurses in
the NHS now last week the government
announced some proposals to deal with
the workforce crisis but but there was
no money there was no extra investment
in those proposals there was no there
was no investment to bring back the
training bursary for nurses and midwives
there was no investment to restore the
professional development budgets there's
no guarantees about future pay either
and unless the government start taking
some big decisions around investing in
our staff we're going to continue to be
sure of nurses and doctors in the NHS
and that alter it ultimately means
standards of care falling backwards okay
now move on to other issues at labour of
course one the by-election in
Peterborough even though the show the
vote went down and however lisa forbes
has been criticised for liking your
video and claiming to have not read the
text above which accused her résumé of
having a zionist slave masters agenda
some of your colleagues have said that
she needs to be suspended while it's
investigated what's your view well
Jeremy Corbyn is supported Lisa fobs I
I've known Lisa for a few years I don't
know very well but I've known of her for
a few years I don't believe she's
anti-semitic I think she's made some
pretty terrible mistakes terrible
mistakes that she's apologized for
I think Lisa now has to show and
understand the upsets that she's caused
in the Jewish community and she has to
work with the Jewish communities to
demonstrate to them but she's not
anti-semitic and though liking those
Facebook posts was a genuine mistake she
said she hadn't read the text properly I
think I believe her but I do believe now
she's got to work hard to show people to
show the Jewish community and colleagues
in in Parliament that she's not
anti-semitic and she's prepared to
engage with the communities to
demonstrate that what what the lessons
that should be learned from Peter Berg
is it an endorsement of Labor's approach
Jean brexit or is that actually
something that you need to examine a
little bit more critically given the
fact that no party's over one of my
election with a lower voter well I mean
it was a remarkable result for labour
and I really do pay tribute to the
thousands of members who are out
campaigning on the streets and also to
Louise Hague and Vernon co2 to Labour
MPs who masterminded the campaign I mean
they're both exceptional campaigners and
Louise is really one of our rising stars
and Berlin's an excellent MP so I paid
tribute to both of them but we
campaigned on local issues we campaigned
on the state of the NHS we campaigned on
the police cuts in Peterborough we
complained on them on the Tory local
councils or to failure to deal with
fly-tipping in the area and I think what
Peter Bush shows is despite all the the
fizz and froth in Westminster about the
brexit party in Nigel Farage
it's a reminder that Nigel Farage does
not have any answers to the big issues
facing the country when it comes to the
future the NHS he wants to privatize the
NHS when it comes to the future of our
schools when it comes to the future of
policing and actually these are the
issues that people still care about on
the doorstep and I think that's why I
label one that by-election in Peter last
week and then just finally I want to
finish with a story that many people
feel very strongly about we've seen
these protests haven't we outside a
school in Birmingham from parents who
are angry about same-sex couples being
included in the relationship education
that these children are receiving now a
Labour MP for the area robert roger
God's if his backed those protesters and
their right to demonstrate
should he lose the whip for it well
people have a right to protest but
people don't have a right to intimidate
teachers it's a bully to bully parents
which I believe has been going on I'm
not I'm not burning MP and Peter I
haven't followed it as closely as
there's colleagues in Birmingham have
but that's what I understand has been
happening and of course we all support
religious so astutely personal and
sexual education in schools we have to
be sensitive of course the different
religious groups but it's important that
our children understand these issues and
and and have and have that level of
education that's the Labour Party
position now I disagree with Roger God
safe and and I think that people in the
parliamentary party will know that I've
taught them to talk to him but it is
important that children get a proper
personal and social and sexual and sex
education in schools should he lose the
whip or be suspended
well I I'm not sure if he should lose it
should lose the whip but I mean he has
to understand that his labour party
policy to support this education in
schools